le physique d'Anne Roumanoff ça vous
fait rire
pas puisqu'elle va
est-ce qu'on peut dire que vous êtes
lentille Franck Dubosc vous n'êtes pas
très grand et pas très beau j'ai pas
très sexy et vous êtes très drôle
alors vous appelez Guillaume battron
vous êtes né à Reims il y a 26 ans et
dès votre naissance on constate que vous
souffrez d'un handicap sévère
l'ostéogénèse imparfaite appelée aussi
maladie des eaux de verre et également
maladie de Picasso
le cubisme j'aime beaucoup c'est la même
maladie que le pianiste Michel Le
Petrucciani c'est ça exactement
un peu plus important je crois encore
que moi de mémoire je crois le même qui
vit pendant les concerts il avait des
fractures pendant qu'il jouait au dos il
continue
à un César lui met pas l'empereur la
statuette
vous êtes nul en piano de toute façon
vous décidez de faire rire avec votre
handicap quel handicap
je m'attends je me fais payer pour ça
c'est génial je le mets vachement mieux
j'ai commencé à Montmiral j'ai commencé
la scène à quelle heure j'avais 12 ans
12 ans j'en ai fait pendant 10 ans 10
ans maintenant d'arriver à Paris la
chance que vous avez c'est que depuis
intouchable le handicap c'est tendance
on a invité dans l'espoir
alors Guillaume tous les vendredis et
samedi à 20h vous êtes sur la scène du
Petit Théâtre du Gymnase il y a des
places réservées aux personnes valides
là-bas
on y pense on y pense alors votre
première vanne quand vous arrivez sur
scène je l'adore on me demande souvent
est-ce que handicapé dans ce métier
c'est bien alors je réponds quand je
pense qu'il y a des gens qui ont des
handicapés dans leur famille qui vont
jamais les voir
payer pour avoir un cours qu'on n'est
pas
c'était pas gagné pour moi
alors vous dites également un truc
énorme contrairement à ce qu'on pense je
suis heureux
[Applaudissements]
et puis c'est pas parce qu'on a
handicapé qu'on est forcément honnête
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors on peut rire de votre handicap
mais peut-on rire de tout on va faire
une interview peut-on rire de tout
[Musique]
alors Guillaume est-ce que Dieudonné qui
se moque de la Shoah ça vous fait rire
moi l'humour à partir du moment où ça
divise plus que ça rassemble ça je sais
pas ils sont pas pressés encore de
l'humour quoi le sketch de Patrick
Timsit sur les handicapés ça vous fait
rire
donc ça passe moins bien
Guillaume qui demande à un handicapé qui
est au premier rang dans une salle de
spectacle encore ce de s'en aller parce
que ça le gène ça vous fait rire
et ça choque personne intouchable ça
vous a plu c'est très très bon film par
contre faudra peut-être de nous faire
croire que les handicapés roulent en
Maserati aéroport
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
François Feldman qui dit au Téléthon
tout le monde debout ça vous fait rien
mais tellement les moments de solitude
comme ça fait à regarder c'est jouissif
quoi le physique d'Anne Roumanoff ça
vous fait rire
pas plus
quand vous voyez dans un miroir Ça vous
fait rien
ça dépend en fait ça dépend de comment
je suis coiffé en fait voilà bravo
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
Lady tube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu